bonjour christopher yano bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france ce matin alors en hongrie en
autriche ou en grèce on l'a vu on
redoute cette crise afghane et surtout
le même scénario qu'en 2015 quand plus
d'un million de migrants ont afflué sur
l'europe est ce que cette crainte est
justifiée selon vous
ont tous dû arrêter il faut regarder un
petit peu les perspectives historiques
qu'est ce qu'on a constaté en 2015 on a
constaté que les systèmes de protection
des frontières de la zone schengen dont
la hongrie est effectivement la
frontière est et tennis et une pression
énorme alors bien entendu je comprends
tout à fait bien que nous avons une
obligation de solidarité humaine vers
tout le monde cependant il faut quand
même faire une distinction très
importante entre l'immigration régulière
ou légale l'immigration illégale et je
pense que c'est justement ça une des
questions de base principale qui a dû
être adressées en 2015 mais suite à un
influent de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes je pense qu'il
était tout à fait évident que les
systèmes en place notamment l'accord de
dublin de l'union européenne n'ont pas
nécessairement qu gérer cette affaire de
manière normale et on est on a vu les
conséquences aussi sur cette vague
migratoire en allemagne sur le plan
sécuritaire qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
redoute la hongrie qui de nouveaux
renforts ses frontières comme elle
l'avait fait on s'en souvient en 2015
je pense que le principe de base c'est
effectivement
comédie devant votre concurrence au
précédent le président serbe monsieur
boutique c'est que on reconnaît que la
hongrie et les pays de l'est ce ne sont
pas nécessairement enfin les pays de
l'est de l'europe de l'est et de leurs
centrales ne sont pas nécessairement les
destinations de ces de ces personnes
mais le point soulevé par le chancelier
autrichien monsieur courte c'est ainsi
que monsieur boutique se découvre pas
être nécessairement la zone de parking
pour les migrants parce que c'est d'une
part un statut temporaire pour ces gens
et d'autre part ça mais quand même une
pression énorme déjà sur les services
social et sur les pays en question
je sais que je sais que la hongrie et
même son gouvernement était considéré
dans 2015 comme l'enfant terrible de
l'europe parce qu'il avait monté une
frontière cependant je tiens à noter que
maintenant six ans plus tard d'une part
le constat c'est effectivement que ce
n'est pas nécessairement une situation
tellement utopiste qu'on l'aurait
souhaité et où on peut recevoir ou en
mesure ou bien où ces pays ont la
capacité de recevoir ou d'accueillir des
centaines de milliers de gens je pense
que tout à fait maintenant on peut voir
que la pologne et montre une barrière de
son côté de la grèce fait de même
lagrasse également on voit là je pense
qu'un des pays balkans a aussi décidé
excusez moi je ne suis pas tout à fait
sur lequel et je pense que ce sont des
faits alors nous avons évidemment des
systèmes en place la question maintenant
et les systèmes qui ont été renforcées
au cours des six dernières années
sur un plan physique donc notamment des
barrières mais aussi sur un plan
administratif et juridique est ce qu'on
a bien pu gérer d'arrivée de tellement
de personnes comme le dit comme une
petit plusieurs la hongrie la pologne la
slovaquie et même la roumanie ce sont
des pays transitaires évidemment ce
mille pression dans l'autre question par
contre c'est que les pays destinations
notamment l'allemagne et rendre potable
france par exemple comment est-ce qu'ils
peuvent gérer ça parce que je pense que
les systèmes qui sont en place par par
par paris sont mises en place par les
ong
bien que ce soit un petit peu un système
idéaliste qu'on va gérer comme
d'ailleurs l'a dit madame merkel la
chancelière allemande verschaere basse
je pense qu'il faut vraiment se poser la
question six ans plus tard quand est ce
qu'on a vraiment plus gérer ça de
manière bien de man group correct et à
long terme qui est bénéficiaire qui
bénéficie tout le monde ainsi qu'une
grand ainsi tués lundi dans des pays qui
les accueillent ça veut dire on va
réussir effectivement c'est ce qu'avait
dit la chancellière allemande en 2015 on
a vu le résultat s'appelle vraiment été
le cas
lors up pour vous agitez le suffisamment
justement pour tenter d'apporter une
réponse à ces vagues migratoires
je pense qu'une question beaucoup plus
de base c'est que il bat qui est un
conflit de principe donc dans certains
dans dans une partie de l'europe ou à
des institutions européennes on est de
l'avis que on a cette obligation de
solidarité
peu importe des réalités et de l'autre
côté on dit quand même que oui la
solidarité c'est quelque chose
d'important et des biens mais quand même
nous avons comme chaque état comme
chaque chaque gouvernement à mon avis
les gouvernements ils ont une obligation
fondamentale premièrement vers leurs
propres citoyens d'assurer la sécurité
et d'assurer que la vie se passe
normalement alors évident si on a un
déficit ont créé façon de vous couvrir
cet enjeu sécuritaire c'est un vrai
enjeu selon vous
madame je pense que il faut toujours
regarder les circonstances il faut
toujours regarder les développements et
les changements je pense que d'une part
on peut dire qu'il ya des changements
positifs avec le fabrique de la société
qui devient un plume qui multiplierait
par contre de l'autre côté on peut pas
nier qu'effectivement il ya parfois est
très souvent des problèmes d'adaptation
de sécurité et de baise et de principes
qui sont en confrontation avec les
principes qui sont déjà établis alors on
a une présidence slovène pour l'instant
qui semble assez réticente à cette
question migratoire qui bloque aussi
dans quatre mois ce sera au tour de la
france est-ce que vous pensez que la
situer la situation reste compliquée
pour les états membres selon vous
madame étant donné que l'europe est
directement accessible
du pays le plus chaud maintenant comme
on lui dit l'afghanistan où on vient de
devoir débâcle remarquable absolument
absolument ahurissant qu'après une
vingtaine d'années et 2000 milliards de
dollars dépensés maintenant de nouveau
le pays est en crise totale je pense que
maintenant effectivement nous allons
voir nouveau une vague migratoire du
moins je ne suis pas expert en matière
de migration mais je pense que c'est
tout à fait raisonnable de penser qu'on
aura maintenant des difficultés dans les
mois à venir avec du nouveau encore une
vague d d'énormément de personnes qui
sont en fuite quand sebastian course dès
qu'il faut que les pays voisins
accueille ses réfugiés c'est évidemment
hors europe est ce que vous pensez que
c'est un un dossier en tout cas une
solution a
appuyé par l'europe
en toute vérité
c'est une question qui est difficile
c'est une question très difficile parce
que les pays voisins donc les pays
avoisinants de l'afghanistan ils vont
ils à m'en dire que bien sûr sur le base
de solidarité on voit un accueillir
quelques-uns mais je pense que ces pays
eux mêmes font face à leurs propres
problèmes oublions
depuis un an et demi dans une situation
de crise sanitaire qui met énormément de
pression sur les états partout au monde
je pense que le principe de par contre
probablement déclarer par monsieur
course or je ne le connais pas
personnellement je n'ai pas discuté de
ces terres de cette affaire avec lui je
pense que à son avis nous devons pour
revenir sur le conflit entre les
arrivants et le peuple qui élit les gens
en europe donc on peut voir qu'il ya
quand même eu pas mal de tension alors
monsieur cours se voulait probablement
dire que avec une situation où ces gens
restent dans la région de l'asie du sud
et dans les pays avoisinants qui ont des
valeurs d des religions de semblable
peut-être que ce serait plus possible d
intégrer c'est peut-être son principal
mais je ne sais pas merci beaucoup
christophe feria nos d'avoir répondu ce
matin en direct à nos questions sur arte
france